hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show
and guess what i'm animators
so i'm entirely sure how well this is
going to go
this is very new to me and i didn't
entirely know what i'm doing
but i thought since i've been on this
platform for a year now
um i would in this video talk about
who i am and why i do this channel and
what i plan to do the channel
so um the big
elephants in the room that is myself and
um this new animation this probably
won't be
much more than just an introductory
thing because obviously
this has been an absolute nightmare to
try and work out but
partly i'm just trying to learn how to
animate and overall improve
the quality of my videos so
obviously i still have bar science i am
scientists
i'm a phd student and so
in these videos we'll talk about a
variety of topics
and uh they'll range from
like science based proper like in-depth
stuff
to book reviews and book summaries
got some more general sciencey stuff
whether it's looking at high-tech
companies
or just doing random videos like this
um hopefully as my animation improves i
can also
more entertaining yeah i think having
good quality
uh production and audio is very
important so
what type of science do i actually look
at well i currently
mainly focus on cellular senescence and
a protein called p53
but i'm also very much interested in
aging research and
the use of crispr and genome medicine
and to be honest i'm pretty much
interested in a wide variety of science
also including neuroscience and
space so expect a variety of topics
also now that i can talk like this i
might even be able to do interviews or
something
like that honestly i don't really know
but i also do find this whole
animating thing it's taking a lot of
time but hopefully i will be able to
improve my skills
anyway um i thought this video was a bit
random
and apologies for being short and a bit
yeah
strange but um i just wanted to say that
i am trying to work
on improving this channel and typically
making it more exciting and
interesting so expect exciting things
this way coming soon at some points in
the future
goodbye
you